welcome to this course about pointers in
C this introductory course was expertly
created by Jalal perfect for absolute
beginners this Visual and code Rich
course will help you understand why
pointers are crucial in manipulating
data values pointers are variables that
store the memory address of another
variable they point to the location of
data in memory with a bunch of examples
this course demystifies pointers and
their various uses covering topics such
as passing by reference versus value
void pointers arrays and more so buckle
up and get ready to demystify the world
of pointers in C hello my friend welcome
to Free code Camp the best place in the
internet where you can learn to code for
free fantastic mesmerizing beautiful
today I'm gonna talk to you about
pointers yeah another course on pointers
why is that well because I want to add
something I want to tell my points
related to these very tricky idea that
is very tricky concept I will try to do
my best basically disease the video I
used to need when I started to learn how
to code so this is like an explain like
M5 explain like I'm a beginner pointers
so this is going to be very Visual and
very code based I'm gonna do a lot of
examples and hopefully you are gonna
tame these complex principle and start
to the reference all the way down this
is my goal to do that we have to build
up from first principle so we're gonna
start from the very very beginning my
friend when I say the very beginning I'm
saying what is a computer we start from
there so to explain really what is a
computer you need a course on computer
architectures we don't have the time and
we don't want to do that so we need a
trick we need a way to explain a very
difficult Concept in few words well
abstraction right abstract action is the
key to collapse difficult complex
entities into manageable ideas right we
want to collapse complexity into
intelligible models that's what we're
gonna do now I'm gonna try to explain to
you what is a computer in a nutshell so
let's pretend an alien is coming to the
planet and is asking to yourself hey how
does your body work what is going on
there well it's kind of a tricky
question right because there is a lot
that is going on you can start to
explain to the alien well you know we
are made up of atoms especially we are
made up of carbon we can consider
ourselves like carbon machines some
hydrogen some oxygen some nitrogen and
yeah kind of complex right if you want
to describe yourself in a Rick and Morty
fashion like saying every atom what he's
doing well I guess you're lost a better
approach I would argue is to tell the
alien well you know I have some systems
inside myself that are providing some
functionality for example I have the
nervous system which is composed of some
organs these organs cooperate together
to process my reality right something
like that in the same Vibe you can say
well I have a digestive system that is
processing food that I take from nature
and this food is converted to energy
energy that I can use for my nervous
system to process reality but I don't
know as well for my muscles so I have
fuel to move around this body you got
the point right you explain reality at a
specific level you don't want to explain
from an atom level right it's too low
you cannot explain as well from a
cellular standpoint right still too low
you talk on a level of systems right you
simply say I have the system that is
providing this function this other
system that is providing this function
all together these systems provide me
that's what is going on well in the same
Vibe I want to explain you what is a
computer at the end of the day a
computer is just a super fancy
calculator if you want especially when I
code when when I write my C programs I
perceive the computer just a simple
arithmetical logical calculator and a
place in which I can stock all my
numbers so I see the ram the the memory
of the computer as a big chunk of boxes
with a specific ID with a specific
address you will see in this video this
is the gist of IT addresses indeed
pointers on the other hand I see a
calculator a calculator which is an
arithmetical logical calculator that is
able to perform indeed arithmetic and
logical operations so logical operations
entails something like is this number
equal to this one is this number less
than this one and so forth very simple
stuff so that's basically it that's our
perceive my computer an arithmetical
logical calculator and a place in which
I can stock numbers that will be
processed by these arithmetical logical
calculator okay of course in the real
Hardware I'm talking about the CPU which
is the central processing unit you can
see in the image that the CPU has inside
the ALU which is The arithmetical
Logical calculator I was talking to you
about arithmeticological units inside
this CPU we have also the registers
which are intermediate places in which
we perform the operations in
intermediate places in which we stock
numbers and then we have the giant Ram
giant quote-unquote giant because it can
be four gigabytes eight gigabytes 16
gigabytes and so forth okay so let's
dive into the ram a little bit more I
told you that I post receive the ram as
a series of post boxes essentially with
a specific address every post box is a
byte okay you know this stuff very well
and every bite is just the line of eight
light bulbs as you can see every byte
has a specific tag which is the address
of the byte so I have the physical view
of the ram which is a chip and The
Logical view of the ram which is my
programmer perceived view of what this
chip is offering me right a series of
bytes as easy as that okay so we have
this view of what is the memory so
inside this memory I told you that there
are these boxes I told you that these
are bytes and what is a byte a byte is
eight light bulbs of course this is an
abstraction for a transistor but we can
perceive like a light bulb that can be
turned on and off a byte isn't it a byte
a chunk of information I can stock a
specific pattern inside this byte okay
given that I have eight bits I can have
256 possible configurations so every
configuration is gonna mean a specific
number from 0 to 200 f55 of course in a
binary way in a binary base because we
are dealing with a binary machine of
course these light bulbs can be turned
on and off in a binary fashion the name
byte is just a kind of joke because four
bits are enabled so
everywhere in computer science there is
plenty of these kinds of joke you will
find out and as you can see uh here I
have the the address of the byte which
is a number you see this strange number
with symbols but this is an hexadecimal
notation this is an hexadecimal number
but keep in mind that this is just
another way of representing a value I
can write the number 42 in hexadecimal
in binary in octal this is just a
different way of representing the same
thing you can make a parallel for
example if you say I previous ciao all
these things mean the same thing they
mean I but they are in different
languages so the value is the same only
the symbols are changing so it's just a
number that tag is just a number which
is the address the location in memory of
this byte so inside these bytes I can
put stuff right I can put numbers to be
more technical I can put data types in
CF these data types I have char short
int long floats double to be more
pedantic short and longer just
qualifiers they are short ins and logins
but we can consider them like data types
per se right when I declare a variable I
just use short and long I I'm never
right short intone logins but this is an
aside this is not important okay from
this slide you have to understand a few
key ideas so the data type is of a
specific size as you can clearly see
from the image you have a chart which is
one byte and you have a long which is
eight bytes generally speaking depending
on the machine for example in my Macos I
have a long which is 8 bytes generally
speaking this is true even for you I
guess so the data type is gonna
discipline the size that we're gonna ask
to our compiler in the RAM and of course
the data type is going to discipline the
way in which bits are going to be
arranged so we have two families
basically we have the integer type and
the real type the way we stock data is
qualitatively different in it when we
stock float we have a different pattern
configuration when we stock real numbers
we have one bit for the sign which is
equal for both and then we have some
bits related to the exponent so we have
a qualitatively different way of
stocking these numbers in memory you
will see later we are gonna dig a little
bit about this idea so key idea integer
types and real types have a different
way of encoding in memory minor binary
speaking so the bits are going to be
arranged differently you will see with a
clear example later and depending on the
specific data type you're gonna take
much or less memory okay if I ask for a
long I'm asking for a big chunk of
memory 8 bytes if I ask for a chart I
just need one byte in the denature
typically we stock charge but at the end
of the day a chart is just one byte
integer it is an integer indeed okay so
we have a ram we can stock data inside
this Ram that can be in the real and
integer form depending on how big these
numbers are gonna be I'm gonna take less
or more bytes so as you can see I can
write numbers inside my Ram to me it's
just a piece of paper in which I can
write numbers numbers that I will
process with my algorithm okay that's
all there is I see the ram like a piece
of paper in which I can write stuff of
course this stuff is going to be a
number of course this number is going to
be in a binary form because we have
light bulbs that we can manipulate but
at the end of the day with these numbers
I can create everything I can create
this video that you're now watching so
let's make a clearer example there are
electrical binary state is giving some
meaning is conveying some meaning in
this case I've declared the variable
which is MB and I assign the value 42 to
this variable as you can see the bits
are tuned accordingly right here I have
a one zero one zero one zero this is
indeed the binary configuration of the
number 42. I hope you know how to
translate from binary to decimal if you
don't know just watch your videos very
simple so here I've written in a space
in memory which is a that specific
address the value 42 the specific
configuration the specific details by
which numbers are stocked is called
ndnis if you want to search difference
between Little Engine and begin them but
again this is not related to our topic
let's focus only on the number itself
here as you can see we have a binary
configuration that is conveying the
number 42 cool now let's watch the
binary configuration of the number 42.0
as you can see it's totally different
it's totally different because as I told
you we have a standard that we're
following basically Engineers gathered
and decided that okay this is the best
way to stock a float number for various
reasons and we have these eight bytes
that are the exponent for floats now the
idea that I want to convey to you is
that the bits are totally different keep
in mind this idea because it's going to
be useful in the video where we're gonna
just do some pointer
manipulation so to make a tldr of these
introductory Parts by now we haven't
talked about pointers at all but I think
it's useful to have this introduction to
be everyone on the same page so we have
an electrical notepad the place in which
we stock numbers the keyboard is my
pencil right is my electrical pencil I
input inside my Ram the numbers thanks
to the code I'm going to write and the
CPU is my arithmetical logical
calculator every time I say if a equal b
or if I say printf a per B well all
these operations are going to happen
inside the sensor Processing Unit which
is just a place in which processing is
happening so keep in mind this view you
have a place in which you can give the
input to the computer application which
is stock number a place in which you
process number and a place in which you
see the results a super fancy calculator
my friend you see you can do this stuff
analogically right with a later and a
piece of paper or you can do with
computers that are much much better much
much faster and you you can do of course
algorithm with computers so to make
calculations automatic so this is the
intro this is the view
um which I think it's fairly useful to
understand pointers and we are ready to
go okay okay this is all cool my
computer is a fancy calculator and a
piece of paper but go to the point cut
to the Chase and indeed I will now we're
gonna talk about the main point namely
the main function you surely know that
the operating system is the master
program that is taking control of all
the resources inside your computer right
it's the king is the medium between me
and the bourbon Hardware this is a super
complicated program that is able really
to control the machine at the lowest
level of reality every time I create a
program I'm asking the operating system
to give me some Computer Resources
inside my programs I have a special
function which is the main function I
call it the queen function because it's
gonna be the first one that is gonna
spark that is going to emit all the
process a process is a fancy word for
referring to a program that is running
so first of all let's clarify what is a
function well at the end of the day a
function is a black box magic is a piece
of code that is able to perform a
specific task the best example I can
think of is the printf how many times
you have used the printf function
without knowing absolutely anything you
have a piece of code that has been
written by someone else you can use
including the summary input output and
boom you have it in the terminal the
string hello world you don't know a
lines of the implementation of printf
nonetheless you use on a daily basis
That's The Power of abstraction That's
The Power of functions so to me it's a
black box I have an API that has been
given in which it is written which are
the specific inputs that I have to put
inside parentheses and the specific
syntax and given that I can use the
function very easily of course I'm
talking about black boxes referring to
others people code if you have to
implement your own functions of course
you know what is going on underneath
they would write the thing is that with
code we generally leverage other people
code already written so for us the black
box magic is a really good math for so
now let's clarify why the main function
is the queen well every program can be
composed of many many functions for
example I don't know Facebook Facebook
is composed of many many functions for
example low world is composed of the
main function and the printf two
functions so a very simple program
generally speaking we can think about a
process composed of many functions so we
have this situation here we have the
main function that is called Link in our
function as well as calling another
function and so forth many many
functions called link one each other and
of course I'm gonna have the return
values for all the functions and a
process overall is this giant calling of
functions on each other so we have all
these black magic boxes that are
cooperating on each other to perform a
specific task to perform a specific
application right domain is pretty
important because it's the Tinder is the
one that is gonna Spark all this madness
of functions calling on each other okay
pretty cool but where is all this action
well again we have to ask the operating
system for resources especially memory
and that's exactly what is happening
when we launch a process we ask the
operating system for some memory and
that's what we're gonna get we're gonna
get so-called process memory layout
which is this very strange
arrangement of memory we have a stack
Heap the data and the text so these are
sections that are going to contain
pieces of your process for example in
the text you're gonna have machine
instructions in the data you're going to
have for example Global static variables
in deep you have the memory which is
going to be allocated dynamically or at
runtime and in the stack is where all
the action is taking place so to make it
very simple the operating system is
controlling all the ram all the
resources and is saying okay I have this
process I need to give him a specific
spot in memory because he has to perform
his stuff so it's going to say okay take
this field in memory do your stuff and
then give me back I need the control
back that's what is happening so let's
zoom in a little bit and let's try to
understand better what is going on this
my friend is the run is the place in
which you stock your numbers you can
view the ram as a chip or you can view
as a programmer the ram as a logical
contiguous series of bytes here is where
your process is gonna take his piece of
memory to perform its calculations so if
we zoom in what do we see well we see
something like that your processing is
taking this lies of memory of course
this is a super mega abstraction this is
more complex than that this is not all
contiguous and yeah you know that it's
more reality is always more complex but
we want to grasp the principles so the
idea is that we take a slice of memory
and inside that slides all the action is
going to take place of course we're
gonna focus our attention in the stack
because here is where all the action is
gonna take place right we have the main
function that is calling another
function and so forth you can have call
to malloc so we have also the IP that is
involved and other details but initially
we're gonna focus on the stack so I
think you have already all the tools to
understand what is going on with
pointers everything is happening in the
ram your process is a living being that
is calling functions one each other to
perform a specific task
every thing as a specific address okay
these addresses are Pointers my friend
so now we go deeper okay my friend we
are ready to start our journey into
pointers and we are gonna start with
variables of course pointers are just
addresses to variables so we have to
understand super well this this concept
now we have this frame of mind that the
ram is just a fancy uh notebook right in
which I can write stuff in a binary
fashion because we are dealing with
electricity and with binary entities
namely transistors that here are just
light bulbs now let's make a simple
example as you can see here I have a
little main program that is gonna
declare a variable and B and assign the
value 42. so what is happening here with
this code very simply I'm going to write
somewhere in memory in my Ram this
number 42 so I'm gonna turn on and off
the bits accordingly for the number 42 I
have one zero one zero one zero as you
can see here from the least significant
byte okay so I have long story short
four bytes depending on the machine but
generally speaking it's four bytes
allocated and I have the value one zero
one zero one zero which is inside these
four bytes NB is going to be the tag for
us us for humans for programmers but
from a computer standpoint we have only
addresses of course so tldr we have
Somewhere In My Memory some bits which
are turned on and off now let's watch
again this little program
um from a stock perspective because you
know right when I have a process I have
my operating system that is giving me a
space in memory the process memory
layout and all the action is going to
happen inside stack the data and the
text and all the segments that I showed
you in the previous video so the stack
discipline namely the allocation and the
allocation of all the functions inside
my process happens inside the stack of
course so here I have the allocation of
my main inside my main I have the
creation of this variable NB so I have a
local variable which is inside the
function frame of the main function a
function frame in this case the main
function frame is the specific space
relegated to the main function so the
main function as this specific frame to
perform its stuff so inside this
function frame I have the creation of my
variable and B okay let's zoom in a
little bit so we can understand better
here I have my stack and inside my stack
I have this frame in which my main
function lives and inside this Frame I
have some bits which are turned on and
off so that's some worry memory is the
space given by the operating system
where the process can do its own
business of course now we are inside the
main function frame because we are
inside that function
now you see that the variable NB as a
specific address right I want to stress
out that this is not a real deal this is
not the real headrest physical address
this is not what you find inside your
real Ram indeed this is a virtual
address uh basically we have the
operating system which is a juggler he's
a magician he's doing all the tricks to
optimize performance as long as we are
concerned we don't really care for us
programmers this is the address of the
variable then we have some other pieces
like the memory management unit that are
going to make all the necessary
computations to match virtual and
physical editors but we don't care we
don't care we work on a higher level of
abstraction our process really thinks
that has unlimited memory thanks to this
magic of the operating system but let me
repeat to you we don't care by now we
want to stick with principles so an
address is an address now let's watch
together a little program so we can
really observe the stack discipline and
what is going on inside the stack so
here I have a stupid program made up of
a few functions so I declare in my main
the variable and B like before you just
saw right so our program starts of
course from the queen function name is
gonna declare and assign the value for
true to the variable and B so we have
four bytes in memory that contain the
value for two one zero one zero one zero
in binary and then we reach the point of
change value so we have a function
called change value is a function that
essentially tries to change the value of
the variable let's see what happens here
so once we reach change value we stop
the execution of the main and we
allocate space for the change value
function as you can see the stack has
grown and now we have this new
allocation the stack counter-intuitively
grows from top to bottom for historical
reasons but this is indeed a growth so
we have the main function that is
stopped link and now we are playing the
change value function what is happening
here we have this function that is
taking as an input NB okay so our
variable inside Main and it's trying
allegedly to change the value of NB to
another value which is 1 337 okay
hmm what do you think is gonna work this
uh little program can the function
change value indeed change the value of
NB well let's try so we have the
execution of ND equal 1337 and then we
have the the allocation of course of the
function because we have finished a
function finishes when we reach the
final closing curly brace cool now we
are back to the main we can play again
the function and now we have the code to
the printf function from the printer
function you know very well has to print
the value of NB so we call the printf
boom we have the allocation but now as
you can see the printf is printing 42
again so my change value function hasn't
worked or is it namely the function
worked but maybe I didn't quite
understand what was going on right so
what is the issue here what is the
problem let's try to understand and
deconstruct this issue so now we stop at
the moment in which uh we were calling
the change value function so I have my
main function frame and then I have my
change value function frame as you can
see so I have my variable NB both in
Main and in change value but let's watch
more carefully what is going on here so
I have my uh frames right my main
function frame and my change value
function frame inside the stack as you
can see I have NB both in main right and
then I have also NB which is in my
change value function frame right so
immediately what can I understand well I
have two variables they have the same
value the same name but they are
different they are in different spots in
different places in memory so NB in main
is a different variable respective to NB
which is in change value and this is
tricky right same name same value you
they are the same nope it is not the
case the thing is that when we call some
functions the arguments are passed by
value as we say in C pass by value is a
fancy way of saying it well the variable
is going to be copied so what is really
changing change value is a copy of the
variable it is not the variable which is
in main you see and if you watch
carefully we have the addresses which
are different they are pretty close
because they both live inside the stack
and one function is just calling one
another so they are very very close but
nonetheless they have different
addresses that's the main area and to
make it clear and B in change value the
argument name and B could have been
different like for example fubas we
don't really care because there are
different things so what is happening
here when I change value NB 1337 what is
really happening well the function is
changing the value of its own copy and
it's not changing the value of MB which
is in the main function you see that's
the catch so let's watch what is really
happening we have our variable in change
value that boom is changing its value as
you can see I've changed the binary
configuration now these uh binary
state is representing the value 1337 but
then what is going to happen well we
have the the allocation of the function
change value so boom and in the main
function I call again the printf but the
printf is getting the old virtue right
because I've changed the value which was
in another stack frame so nothing really
changed so printf simply keep using the
usual and The Virtue and the reprintf is
not aware that we don't understand
pointers my friend so what can we do if
I want to change and be which lives
inside the main function frame what is
the trick here well my friend that's
where pointers come handy you see let's
re-watch again the animation I have my
main function inside the main function I
have the variable NB then instead of
calling change value with NB I'm doing
something different I'm using the
Ampersand operator this Ampersand
operator is given the address of the
variable to the cold function in this
case change value so I have to change
also the change value because this time
we are getting different kind of inputs
look carefully change value is taking
this time a pointer to NB we use the
asterisk operator and as well NB equal
1337 we have to change a little bit we
have to say at and B so I'm gonna
dereference these indeed these the
reference operator we will see later so
this time the input the data type that
change value is taking is not anymore a
variable but is a pointer is this big
boy here he is 8 bytes generally
speaking but depending on the machine
that is able to point indeed somewhere
so this variable contains the address of
another variable and if you watch
carefully you see the binary
configuration of this variable which is
exactly the address of NB so this
pointer is a special kind of data that
is able to a point Somewhere In My
Memory we can make indeed reference to
something which is not here not in my
local frame not in my local function
frame indeed when we say the reference
we are meaning reference to something
which is not here which is far think
about the word I don't know uh
deportation bring someone far that's the
idea here we'll make you reference to
something for the reference and when I
say star and B I'm saying hey go in the
address pointed by unbi and put there
the value
1337. okay so we have this condition
this time let's watch the uh stack
frames as you can see I have NB and both
MB so I have my main function frame and
then I have my change value function
frame but this time thanks to NB what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna de-reference this
pointer boom so I can access the NB
which is in the main function and then I
just do at NB I can read in this fashion
as the risk MB is equal to 1 337. now
look carefully what is going to happen
boom I'm gonna change the value there
okay so thanks to the magic of pointers
I'm able to go somewhere else and change
values this my friend is called passing
a value by reference not by value but by
reference so we give to the function a
specific address a specific place to
watch if we want to do its business so
pass by reference which is very
different from passing an argument by
value right you just saw so we have the
change value function that gets the
allocated when we reach the final third
brace and then we call again the printf
this time the printf is getting as an
input and B which has been changed you
see I have 1337 so everything works
thanks to the power of pointers thanks
to the power of the referencing making
reference to something which is not in
my stack frame and we already scramble
you have the tools to understand
everything about pointers okay my friend
so here my friend I have the actual code
as you can see my main function in which
I declare my variable and D equal 42 and
then I call my change value the the
function you just saw I call my change
function here I call the variable and
full bar just to stress out that this is
gonna be different this is gonna be a
copy of NB and you just saw that this
program doesn't work let's try out so
I'm gonna run my program and I get 42 as
you can see R is just a function that I
created it's just compiling doing all
the checks and so forth it is like GCC
and then launching a DOT out it's the
same so we watch again the code and this
time we're gonna tweak a little bit
first of all I'm gonna tweak the
Prototype so the function is taking an
address as an input so I have to use the
star I will explain later why here I
don't have the Ampersand because this is
a little tricky the syntax of pointers
is kind of tricky it looks right so here
I have a pointer here I give as an input
an address so Ampersand on B I'm giving
the address of MB and here again I have
to use a pointer here and here I have 2D
reference the difficult part in my
opinion is that declaration and
dereferencing are the same right we have
the same syntax this is tricky but no
not really I will explain to you now
we're gonna run again this program so
I'm gonna run and you can see this time
I have 1337 it works
now let's watch again the classical
example of
um using pointers and this is the swap
function right I have two variables in
my main which are 42 and
1337. I'm gonna print their values then
I call the Swap and then I'm going to
print again as you can see the swap the
reference to the true variable some
person a Ampersand B so my swap is
receiving the addresses of A and B as
you can see from the signature of the
function right I have as an input two
pointers pointer and and pointer and one
then I do my swap routine which is just
making a temporary variable in which I
can stock the value of n then I say at n
is equal to at N1 basically this is a
stupid swap algorithm so let's try to
launch this
and you can see that it works perfectly
so you understand super well by now what
is going on right with this
um pointers so now the tricky part uh
declaration and the reference have the
same syntax uh why doesn't C have a
better Syntax for doing this namely a
different Syntax for your referencing
and a
respectively another different Syntax
for declaring this is confusing
initially it was for me a little
confusing keep in mind this principle I
have that declaration tells me how to
use what does it mean well let's try to
understand together I have here at
Declaration of a variable int and right
a classic collaboration here I read in
this fashion to get an integer just use
n that's why I read given this
declaration let's try another int star n
what is written there well it is written
that I have a pointer to an integer so I
read as a programmer to get an integer
just the reference and you're starting
to understand I guess right here I have
n three which is an array of three
integers but here I read in this fashion
to get an integer you have two index
inside this array a value so in an
expression n square bracket zero one two
is gonna heal an integer the last
example is a function for example you
have a prototype 4 inch and float and
one what do I read well I read that to
get an integer just cool full with the
related inputs so tldr the notation of a
variable declaration is telling me what
you must do to something to get
something of that specific data type
let's apply this principle to pointers
here I have a declaration of different
pointers and you can see I have intent
this is just a variable then I have star
PN and then I have star star piano what
do I read here well I read to get an
integer use n use the identifier the
variable identifier n or you can use
star pn or you can use Stars rpn they
all will heal an integer type when used
in this way in an expression so in my
view in my mind and the claration is an
how to use okay to get a specific data
so here as you can see I have many
different declarations for different
declaration so I declare your pointer a
double pointer a double level pointer
and a three level pointer okay here
given the principle I just told you I
see that I have to use this identifier
variable identifier variable name colors
you want to get an integer here I have
to use starpn to get an integer and so
forth right here I have to use three
times the start on this PPP and to get
an integer
so
um if I want to get for example
an integer from this what shall I do
well I have to use two times the let's
delete this and let's do that printf
percent the new line I have to do to
this boy here uh triple the reference
a triple the reference beat b b n like
that and this is gonna heal an integer
because here is written if you triple
the reference this boy you get an
integer if you single the reference this
boy you get a double pointer to integer
you see you get the catch let's try if
it were so I run the code and as you can
see I get 42 I get the number 42 perfect
because I triple the referenced this now
if I do something like that I do p the
stand form pointer is equal to uh B
another pointer so what do I do I
um double the reference this why a
double D reference well because if I
double the reference this boy I get a
pointer to an integer and here I use PN
which is what a pointer to an integer so
I'm gonna use directly with no the
referencing because this if I use this I
get a pointer to an integer I'm not the
reference you see the the catch my
friend let's watch if it works
okay here I have some controls that I
made so I'm gonna do like that GCC and
then launch boom as you can see they are
equal they are the same right so just
keep in mind what I told you this is an
instruction manual it's telling you how
to use these uh PPP on to get a specific
data type if you do a Tripoli reference
you get an hint if you do a single you
get a double pointer and if you do a
double the reference of this you get a
pointer to an integer you just saw here
that's the idea okay my friend so I
guess uh these declarations are not
going to be difficult anymore now
another question which are the
advantages of passing pointers as
arguments compared to passing by value
is a good question right let's watch
some pros and cons of course everything
in computer science like in life as on
pros and cons so we start by passing by
value of course passing variable by
values are equal to you that they're
just copious it's easy to understand
right it's super easy you pass a
variable and the other function is doing
is business to that variable to that
copy and I have nothing to reference
super simple of course this is safe
because passing only copies is going to
prevent uh some other functions to
change value somewhere else and making
the code overall unreadable and yeah you
are sure that the cold function is not
going to mess up your variables in your
local frame the bad part is that we have
some performance over red of course when
I pass an object by value this object
has to be copied so keep in mind if the
object is very very big you have a very
big memory over red now we cannot really
pass a raise by value they're not copied
because we have a phenomenon which is
the array Decay into a pointer we'll
explain later the relationship between
pointers and arrays but if you have a
struct for example a struct has to be
copied so you have every time to every
function to copy this big boy you can
very easily understand that this is a
big override so another negative part of
passing uh by values is the short reach
right you cannot do what with pointers
you can so this can be good of course
because you have safety but can be also
bad because you're tied to your local uh
frame so this can be a plus or a minus
passing by reference is uh efficient so
you can pass big data structures for
example a big struct and you're gonna
pass only a reference so in the code
function you don't have to copy
everything another plus is that you have
direct access to other places in memory
you just saw with the swap function that
we can go to change stuff in other
places and this is useful if you know
what you're doing and yeah this is a way
to return quote-unquote return multiple
values because with a function in your
site to return only one value right you
have returned the value here we are able
to change stuff in other places so we
can make functions instead have a lot of
functionality side effects of course is
the one I just told you before is that
you can mess up a lot of your code you
can create code which is impossible to
read because you have many functions
that are changing parts of other code
and overall it can be a big overhead to
have many pointers if you write bad code
and of course this is complex taming
pointers is indeed
very complexity this is one of the most
difficult if not the most difficult
argument related to C programming so now
my friend we are going to a website
which is very very useful especially if
you want to learn pointers because this
is a visual tool that allows you to
visualize directly pointer you just type
c tutor on Google and you go into this
website then you just pass some code
like for example here I have this sample
code that now we're gonna check together
so let's watch in the terminal so we
have colors I have created a little
struct which is Fatboy it contains a big
array a big array of 50 elements so not
that big and here I declare one instance
of the objects right so I have my fat
boy then I just put somewhere randomly
in my array the value for two
and then I need just to find these four
issues in my fat boy okay so I call the
function find 42 passing as an argument
fat boy you see so my I have my fine
fortitude as he's taking what well he's
taking a copy of it boy you see he's not
taking a reference these are passing by
by value and then I have some protein
that is searching the position of
Fortune so it's searching where in my
fat boy 42 is okay now let's watch here
the execution in seat user as you can
see I have this uh big boy here
um fat boy
that is a big array you see a big struct
and when I called find virtue I have a
copy of this so I need to pass the
entire copy and this is bad right just
keep in mind that you can have many many
functions this is of of course is going
to impair performance because if you
have to copy it every time all the
things it's gonna take time even though
computers are really fast now let's
tweak a little bit the code I'm going to
change this so I'm going to use
Ampersand fit Boyer as you can see so I
give an address to destruct and and here
in my fine Fortune I'm taking a pointer
so here now I have to tweak a little bit
even near the code I need to use this
special operator this is for struct but
this is not important now
um and here we are now and just use a
loop inside equals 0 I minor that's then
size array
plus plus I I'm gonna do
fat boy V in position I is equal to I
okay this is just a simple uh loop to
put some values inside all the cells so
let's run it here as you can see I have
some random values then I call the
um find 42 giving as an input the
address and then I call the function
boom now look carefully this time you
see I don't have the copy I just have a
pointer I have a pointer to my big array
so my fine Fortune here my function
doesn't really need to have an entire
copy just have a reference so my fine
for you can make a reference to a
variable which is not in its frame it's
somewhere else it's in another place
indeed it's in the main function frame
you see here with this website you can
clearly see the stack and the and the
Heap so here are the functions are
located in the stack so is gonna do its
algorithm
in its own frame looping inside the
variable which is in the main a certain
point is going to find 42 in position 14
which is this one of course this is a
star
just randomly 42 is also a star because
if you watch the ASCII code you will see
that 42 is indeed a star and my friend
you understood why
um passing a value by reference can be
more efficient well you don't have to
copy all the stuff all the time okay
these of course make more sense once you
have big structures for example fat
Boyer which is a big structure a
relatively big other question why
pointers to different data types have
the same size this is a good question
right now I'm gonna propose to you a
little parallel which is Illuminating in
my opinion so if you want to search the
address of I don't know the Empire State
Building or if you want to search the
address of random dude selling or dogs
at Central Park we're gonna get a bigger
address if you want to go in the Empire
State Building given that this is much
much bigger than the selling or dog cars
well of course no my friend an address
is just an address this is something
that telling where something is it
doesn't hold that the object pointed by
this address is big or not this is not
the point of an address so this is the
idea of pointers if we are pointing
something in memory that can be for
example an integer for bytes generally
speaking depending on the system we have
an address of 8 bytes in my machine if
we want to point to I don't know a short
we still have a pointer of 8 bytes if I
want to point to I don't know a double
which is pretty big uh it's eight bytes
as well in my machine I still have the
same pointer I still have the same size
of my pointer you get the point because
all the data have an address which is of
a specific size so keep in mind these
parallel that I made with the Empire
State Building and the signing old dog
dude cars that's the same idea okay
that's the same principle so here my
friend I have a little program that is
showing you this I have a chart a short
an INT a double and then I have a type
big which is just a struct that contains
a big array here I have three six and
one million
integers so I have four megabytes okay
and here I simply print the size of this
is an operator that is giving me back on
any bytes something is Big of the
address of uh C of CH of i d and big so
the address while pointer to do these
objects here all right let's try to
launch this code I have eight which is
the size of the pointer to every data
type to a chart which is the smallest to
Big struct which is the biggest I have
all the times eight now another question
given pointers about the same size we
just saw that why do I need to specify
the point here type this is another good
question right indeed when I declare a
variable I'm telling the compiler hey
dude I want uh an integer so give me my
machine for bytes or I want to Long give
me eight bytes or I want to charge give
me one byte they are all integers at the
end of the day they are stocked in
memory as an integer so here I'm just
saying Hey I want eight bytes or I want
one byte of the integer type I can do
the same line of reasoning with floats
but you got the point right so the type
is uh telling us even how big an object
is of course this is a simplification at
the end of the day is the compiler that
is deciding how big an object has to be
but anyway just uh Linger on the
principle you decide the data type
depending on the size for example if I
want a very little number that is
ranging from uh I don't know from 0 to
100 I can use a chart I can use a chart
as a one byte integer not only for
charts this is an integer of one byte so
I can really use it for a little number
if I want to use so I came very
surgically with data types decide
how much memory I want to use this is
pretty useful right when you want to
have a super control of what is going on
indeed the C programming language is
giving you superpowers in this domain on
the contrary you have pointers that have
all the same size so what is the point
of telling me okay this is a pointer to
an integer rather than pointer to a
chart so here I want to repeat to you
again this point that the binary
configuration of 42 is very very
different from the binary configuration
of 42.0 float right because we have a
different encoding of the binary we have
exponent speeds in the real data types
on the contrary on the integer data type
we don't have this kind of accounting we
have simply the number in a choose
complement fashion so keep in mind this
because we're gonna do a little trick
related to this idea so now I have a
little program uh that we're going to
check to understand why a pointer as a
specific type I have a declaration of a
variable which is an integer in and B
and then I have a declaration of a
pointer you can see int star PTR this
means that if you the reference PTR you
get an integer and B gets the value 42
and PTR gets the address of NB then I
call my printf so I want to print the
the value pointed by PDR and then I do
something peculiar which is disgusting
okay I'm gonna cast PTR to a float star
float pointer what is this casting thing
well the best analogy that came to my
mind is like the real casting when we
want to decide which actors have to play
in in our film right well that's
basically the same idea when we do a
cast we are assigning a role to a
pointer in this case so we are assigning
the role of a pointer to a float to my
pointer so here I'm selling to PTR hey
dude I know that you are a pointer to
any integer but in this time you're
gonna play the role of a pointer to a
float so we're gonna do another Chuck
and we're gonna de-reference again the
pointer but this time of a type float so
here we come my friend this is the
actual program as you can see I have uh
the thing you just saw in the slide the
only thing is that here I have an e
because I want to see in scientific
notation or why is the number is going
to be too little but we can also do like
that
um 0.60 f okay let's try to launch the
program
so I'm gonna launch a look what happens
I have this 42 and then I have this zero
zero zero zero and then I have this
value what is that value my friend so
you just go on this website which is uh
float Xposed in which you can uh play
with floating numbers so now let's try
to do something I write 42 here in
binary of course which is one zero one
zero one zero of course starting from
the least significant byte which is this
one so I have one zero one zero one zero
do you see something that you just saw
five eight eight five four what do you
see here five eight eight five four five
three five five zero five three five
five zero so you see what's happening
here my friend here with this cast I'm
telling a pointer when you're gonna be
the reference read those binaries as a
float not anymore as an integer so
you're pointing to a float now you see
so that one zero one zero one zero is
dereferenced in this fashion it doesn't
see any more for YouTube but it sees
this very little number which is these
five elevated to minus 44. here we can
do in scientific notation essentially
like I did before like that and you will
see the exact same value just you don't
see all these zeros right five eight
eight five four five four of course here
you see a four because we have
um the value rounded and then elevated
to -44 you that's why you have all these
zeros here but anyway you get the point
the pointer type tells the compiler how
to interpret the binary the spotty
memory that it's pointing to so that's
why we have a data type for a pointer
this is crucial all the times you want
to get a specific value let's play a
little bit with this code so we can have
a super good understanding of what is
going on this time I'm gonna do
um a Char for example I'm gonna cast to
a chart and um here I'm gonna write
directly in binary we do we can do that
in C we do one and eight zeros one two
three four five six seven eight and here
I write C what is going to happen in
your opinion let's close let's run okay
uh I cannot do because there's a better
research but I can't these are just
controls flags that I put okay I launch
I get the value 256 but I don't see any
charge why is that well because when I
reference this pointer what I'm gonna
see is only the least significant byte I
charge one byte right so when I
reference I get the zero the normal Char
so that's why I don't see anything here
if it was I don't know a short a short
uh and here I just put uh D so you are
gonna see 256 as well because when I do
reference this pointer this is gonna see
uh this second byte if you want because
the short is two bytes depending on the
data type we are gonna read the
um bytes pointed by the pointer
differently this is not the full story
of this type of pointers and if we have
C that is very consistent and regular in
its approach to address arithmetic its
integration of pointers arrays and
address arithmetic is one of the
strengths of the language you will see
later that there is a big integration
related to arrays and pointers making it
really tricky to differentiate between
arrays and pointers you will see but
keep in mind that erz is written we want
pointer arithmetic to be equal to index
addressing of arrays so let's make a
stupid example don't pay attention to
the binary configuration of the ram this
is just random I want just to make a
point ear about Pointer arithmetic so I
have my pointer pointing to HR a pointer
to char and then I'm going to print
every time the value of this pointer and
only the address
doing some arithmetic as you can see
initially I want to print
um PC pointer to char its value so I'm
going to print that then I'm going to do
PC Plus One boom so as you can see I
Advanced the pointer by one now the
pointer is pointing one position more
and I do pointer C plus two so I Advance
another position and then pointer C plus
three I Advance another position I will
say well that's easy right I have the
pointer that is indeed advancing one
position but this is just the case the
case is that achar is big one byte so
that's why we are advancing one byte at
a time I want you to pay attention to
the fact that a pointer is just a
variable as you can see the binary
configuration of the pointer is changing
as I do pointer arithmetic because this
just a value that can change okay so the
formula to make points for arithmetic is
this one I have the pointer plus n per
size of type pointed so that's why it's
important to know the type of the object
pointed this time I have a chart so it's
easy and let's say is three the size of
chart is one so I have the address plus
three okay now let's watch in our case
this time I'm pointing to another data
type which is a short for example we're
gonna change a little bit the code we're
going to change the value and now what
is going to happen this time when I add
one to PC so look carefully I have this
boom I have the advancement of two bytes
and not only one why is that well you
understood because a short is true bytes
so when I say PC Plus two I get boom an
advancement of other two bytes so four
bytes respective to PC so that's what is
going on my friend you understand super
well that the data type is important
also when we do counter arithmetic you
see so this is gonna discipline how
pointer arithmetic is going to work and
you will see that this maintains uh
highly consistent parallel between uh
pointer arithmetic array indexes indeed
it's like I'm taking the object at
position X so this is just a code that
you saw we are gonna start
um for example with an integer this time
I have a pointer to an integer and we're
going to perform arithmetic with an
integer pointer I'm gonna compile and
then launch as you can see we have an
advancement of what of four right zero
four eight okay why is that well you
understand super well now because an
integer is uh for byte entity if you do
your uh short like in the slide so we
change here to short what is going to
happen well you already know I'm gonna
launch I have an advancement which is
from two to two zero two and four that's
all there is my friend other question
void pointers are confusing let's dig a
little bit when I say that a pointer is
a void pointer what I'm really saying
well I'm not assigning if you want a
roll to my puncher I still don't know
which is the best fit for this specific
pointer so we can say that void is a
generic pointer you should definitely
change the word void to generic in your
mind when you see void just keep in mind
that this is a generic pointer so tldr
void star void pointer means we will let
you know right that's what happens with
actors well we don't know which is the
best role for them you can keep this
parallel in your mind it's pretty useful
now let's see a practical example here I
have a stupid program that is going to
declare in its main volume the usual
value for two and then I have a function
that is called which is print data so
this function is able to print that
specific data given a specific chart for
example I F or c for integer float or
chart the print data function is taking
as an input avoid star data so we have a
generic data that we're going to
interpret inside the function so if we
have the Char I we're going to interpret
the data as an integer f as a float
chart is a Char so you see that inside
the print data function I'm assigning
the role to the void generic pointer
okay let's watch the code okay here we
are as you can see I have my integer
value here and then I just print the
value every time I assigning the role to
my generic data pointer so I'm gonna run
the code and as you can see I have 42 if
this pointer is pointing to an integer I
have the value which you saw before
which is the binary configuration of 42
if it was a float and then I have the
star if it was a Char you understand
everything related to this topic I guess
now when in practice we stumble upon
these void pointers well when you use
the malloc function you see how many
times you have used the Malik namely uh
requesting at runtime some spacing
memory well the malloc is returning a
chunk of bytes in your memory but it
doesn't really care about the data type
that's up on you you are gonna decide
the specific data type the specific role
that the pointer has to play with the
casting right every time you use the
malloc you're gonna get a void pointer
now my friend given that we are talking
about the malloc I want to show you
another little program which can be
Illuminating about the use of pointers
so here in my main I have a declaration
of a pointer right to an integer and
then I assign the value to this pointer
the return value of foo foo is a
function that is returning a pointer as
you can see here and essentially is
returning a pointer to a variable which
is a local one it's returning the
address of n which is a variable inside
that then what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
use Jeff to print the the value pointed
by the puncher okay what do you think
this program can work let's watch out so
I compile and immediately you see that I
have a warning I have a warning address
of Stack memory associated with local
variable and returned is tricky Now
launch and it works no I have my 42. but
now let's try to change a little bit the
heard him I'm gonna uncomment this other
function which is bar and this function
very simply is going to declare a
variable and assign a value that's all
there is that is going to happen in this
code let's try to launch and then try to
deconstruct so I'm going to compile and
launch I get first of all 42 and then I
get 1 337. what happened I mean here I
never changed
um the value of the pointer right it has
always been the same now my friend the
issue with this code is very simple so
when I call the function full I have the
allocation in the stack of this function
right so my main function is going to
stay idle and then Foo is going to
perform stuff essentially it's going to
declare this variable 42 and then it's
going to return uh address to that
variable cool after that what is going
to happen well I have the full function
that gets the allocated from the stack
so I have a variable which is in a place
in the stack which is not allocated
anymore is deallocated then I quote my
printf ever I have 42 because that place
in memory is not overwritten by other
functions then what do I do I call the
bar function so I have another
allocation just above the main like the
foo before and the bar function this
time is declaring another variable it's
declaring this variable here and
assigning another value so the address
that is the one of the previous variable
n which was in full now is the same
address of NB just by chance right
because we know how the stack routine
the stack discipline works we can in a
nakish way assign another value to the
same address so that's why in the second
printf if we print from the same address
we get this other value here so now you
understand very well what is going on
here so why did my look
um I'm gonna say int pointer and declare
a pointer to an integer and here I do
n is equal to my look sides off int okay
and then I say at n so ID reference
designers I say 42 and then I simply
return N I return a pointer so this data
now lives in the and it's not going to
be overwritten because enable we don't
have a nip discipline we don't have an
allocation and the allocation of stuff
so let's watch again the code and this
time I'm going to get 242 of course
right I think that here it's useful to
see visually so we're gonna copy these
and past instituter so we can see what
happens so I'm gonna run I call my
function through as you can see I have
another
stack frame and then I call my malloc as
you can see now we live in deep we're
pointing in a four bytes which are in
the assigned there the value 42 and then
I'm gonna return this pointer as you can
see I have this pointer in the Eep that
gets returned to the main function boom
so now I have a reference to my 42 and
when I say print what is inside PN I'm
gonna print 42. when I call the function
bar here and I get the variable
declaration I don't have any arrays of
previous values like before right I hope
you understand this point but no nothing
because the Heap is there idle nobody's
touching it and here we go so the second
time we're gonna print again for you so
that's all there is and this is a thing
by which the memory in the app is useful
because this is memory that is leading
idle by uh the stack Madness that is
happening allocation and the allocation
stuff okay so this is a silly example of
the mallow function now if you watch
manual mellow we are gonna see what I
used to tell you that every time we are
gonna receive a void pointer from alert
then it's up to us to cast it to the
specific value we want to have okay
another important thing that you have to
keep in mind is that you cannot of
course dereference about Pointer for the
reasons we just explained right what is
the role of this pointer I don't know
how to read the bytes pointed because we
don't have a type so look at this
example I have an integer n and then I
have a void pointer in which I assign
the address of n but when I try to
reference it you see I have a mistake
immediately I'm going to say hey I
actually don't know which is the the
data type pointed out shall I read the
bytes pointed so if we compile I'm gonna
get an error argument type void is
incomplete of course and you understand
super well by now what is going on now I
want to add some more confusion to your
life okay with these pointers and this
is the question of pointer arithmetic
with white pointer do you think it's
feasible well C standard doesn't allow
what pointers aromatic void indeed is a
no type so it's kinda tricky to
understand how to handle arithmetic
right because you know that arithmetic
depends by the size pointed if I'm
pointing to a short I'm gonna jump two
bytes by two bytes but it's kind of
tricky to get the size of a no type
because void is a no type along so sure
we can long story short we can do
pointer arithmetic with pointers what is
going on here my friend well we add a
new extension that can explain better a
glue extension refers to additional uh
stuff that you can do additional
features you can perform with language
beyond the standard beyond the standard
scene in this case we have an extension
which is called pointer arithmetic of
wowing Partners long story short we are
gonna treat a boy pointer as a pointer
to a byte this makes sense right because
when we have a void pointer we are
implying that we have a pointer to a
byte I just have a generic pointer to a
byte so to prove you this uh pointer
arithmetical pointers I have this little
program my usual variable 42 and then I
sign the address of 42 to PTR which is a
void pointer then I do some pointer
arithmetic so I'm gonna print
the the value pointed by the pointer
here you do a type cast just to make the
the reference possible because I cannot
reference avoid pointer so I'm going to
the reference as an unsigned Char why is
that well because an unsigned Char is a
byte if you think about that and then
you hear the magic I'm gonna do PTR plus
plus so what is it feasible PTR plus
plus let's launch the code here I'm
gonna compile with all the flags that I
have as you can see I have error because
I'm using the flag W error this is going
to make of every warning an error but
this will work I have arithmetic on a
pointer to void is a new extension
basically it's telling me hey um
this is something more this is not the
standard C now I compile but aromatic
and then I just launch as you can see it
works I have just the values that are
printed let's do for example
256 I will get 0 1 0 0. Let's watch it
zero one zero zero you see you
understand why I got zero one zero zero
because I have only one one which is the
ninth bit okay the ninth bit is the
least significant bit of the second byte
I hope you understand this point so with
this new extension it is feasible but it
is not
um
a standard C so it is not suggested to
use but now you know that you actually
can okay we already covered a lot of
questions which are kind of tricky right
and now we are gonna go a little deeper
okay my friend now I think you have a
very good understanding of what is a
pointer basically it's just an address
of a variable inside your RAM inside
your memory now we enter a little bit in
murky area indeed we have to understand
what is this correlation between array
and pointers this in my opinion is the
trickiest part related to pointers so
let's start from this definition the
name of an array is a synonym for the
location of the first element so
basically the name of the array is an
alias so to a programmer an array
identifier is almost and this almost is
very big just a pointer because in most
cases arrays Decay into pointers the K
is a fancy word that means loss of type
and loss of Dimension and yeah I know my
friend tricky but I'm gonna try to make
all of this as easy vanilla as possible
so what we're gonna do now we're gonna
create a program that
um
is going to be self-explanatory about
this dance between arraying pointers so
the usual boiler plates so include solar
input output and then as usual my main
function so int main okay you perfectly
know that to create an array you just do
that right you just say for example
let's pretend we have an array of
integers we say int array which is the
name identifier of the array and you can
say 10.
so this is gonna create an object of 10
integers inside your RAM more precisely
inside your main stack frame
now I told you that at the end of the
day the name of the array the array
identifier is basically a pointer to the
first element if I do something like
that printf B new line and I say R I'm
gonna get the address of the first
element so to make the proof I can say
is equal to B and I use here the address
of array the first element array zero do
you agree this is the same right this is
equal to this let's try to launch this
program so I'm gonna compile a very
pointer and then I'm going to launch
as you can see they are two addresses
and they are equal so the name of the
array is this one and this is the
address of the first element so you can
see that they are exactly the same if I
say the name of the array I'm implying
the address to the first element cool so
here I want to create my fake array
using only pointer notation
so first of all I have to create a
pointer so in PTR like that so this is a
pointer and um what shall I do now so
this is a pointer to an integer
essentially like array now the key
difference that it's immediate is that
when you use these array notation you
are allocating in the stack some memory
right you are allocating essentially 10
per 4 so you're allocating 40 bytes this
is an object of 40 bytes this is not
happening with a pointer right I have a
pointer that is pointing to an integer a
random integer so we don't have a
location but we can have a trick to to
to do that
we have a function in it which is called
a locker not a lot used because it it is
not suggested but it exists
so the aloka macro allocates bytes of
space in the stack so you see that's the
key difference between malloc and aloka
we are in the stack we are allocating in
the stack so we have this function that
is able to allocate some space in the
stack essentially like an array right
so now I can do something like that I
can do a locker of course I have to
include my standard Library I call a
locker of what size of int per 10 okay
so unlocker is going to allocate in the
stack 40 bytes essentially the same
thing that is happening here
cool so now I can say
um at PTR plus 0 is equal to 42 as well
as some other examples I can say at PTR
plus 1 and and at PTR plus two
is equal to another number 1037 and
minus 21. let's do the same with the
array with the array notation that you
know pretty well we have array 0 equal
42 I'm gonna copy this and pass and then
I do array in position one is equal to
the same value
as well as for the last
okay we have something which is uh
almost equal do you agree now let's
print the values so I do a loop for in
title zero a minor then 10 and then plus
plus I we are gonna print
um the value which is in the relative
position okay
so we have array in position I we do the
same essentially for my fake array only
I use pointer notation so at PTR plus I
okay of course I have only three numbers
the other numbers are going to be random
but we don't care let's try to launch
this code so I'm gonna compile with all
the flags and as you can see immediately
I have um this warning that is telling
me a Loca is discouraged there is no way
to check for failure and some other
details but we don't care this is just a
sample to understand principles so I'm
gonna compile normally and then I just
launch you see it allegedly works now
let's make the chord more clear in the
middle here I'm gonna put some spaces to
make the code more readable okay put
string choose basis plus the one from
put string is going to be three
okay so I'm going to compile normally
and then I'm going to launch
here it comes I have my first array and
then I have my second array so as you
can see immediately the first three
numbers are the ones essentially like
the real one cool now it is
kinda the same let's try to find some
differences here first of all I would
like to increase directly PTR PTR is
just a simple pointer a simple variable
that I can change so I'm gonna do
directly PTR plus plus I can remove the
braces of course they are not necessary
so I remain with this expression here of
course I have these operators the plus
plus is going to be performed before
because I have associativity that comes
from right to left when we have unitary
operators but nonetheless here I want to
do the same so I'm going to do not array
I
I would like to try to increment this
and the reference because we know that
the name the identifier of the array is
equal to the pointer to the first
element we just saw that let's try
so I'm going to compile and immediately
I get this mistake cannot increment
value of type array of integer of 10
elements so I cannot increase
directly the value of this identifier
strange given that this is just a
pointer right so this is one key
difference between these two I cannot do
that on the contrary
um in the contrary I can do very easily
right with pointers let's try to compile
and launch as you can see it works
correctly no problem
so to make it more equal I'm going to
try to do something I'm gonna say this
is a pointer but this is a constant okay
so here is written this is a pointer
constant to an integer okay so now if I
try to compile I will get almost a
similar thing right because I have the
constant qualified type so basically I
cannot perform pointer arithmetic
directly on the pointer itself basically
I cannot change the value of the pointer
okay so we managed to get a similar
Behavior if you want
indeed when you search a line for
example is an array just a constant
pointer you will find many people that
will argue yeah essentially
an array is almost like a custom pointer
it is not the same but you can consider
an array like a constant pointer of
course these are not the case right if
you want to go deep they are not the
same thing but search by yourself uh is
an array a constant pointer and you will
find some good information now people is
telling that an array is just a constant
pointer because of this you have this
similarity and indeed that's legit in
your mind you can consider
um the name of the uh of an array just a
constant pointer but now I will show you
that this is not quite the case
uh so let's start from the beginning and
let's watch all the similarities between
the two first of all I'm gonna print off
the address of the array and I do person
P okay so I use the array identifier
which is array that you know that is
basically a pointer to the first element
so I can do that
okay here I put this time my pointer
I compile and as you can see
um they are pretty close right they are
equal seven nine three zero seven nine
zero zero they both live in the stack
okay they point in the stack okay so
this is the first point these array uh
and all these elements are living inside
the stack first thing which is equal in
the stack okay as well here in the stack
the other thing that you just saw is
that
um we cannot we cannot increase we
cannot increase r as well as we cannot
increase
um this custom pointer so cannot
increase so this is the same okay we
have two things which are equal now
let's find something which is not equal
and here we're gonna do uh size off
operator I'm gonna use the size of
operator and I'm gonna print F percent
Zoo the size of of array so the size of
R I'm gonna do the same here for my
pointer
so size of PTR
so let's try to launch this time the
code and let's watch if it is exactly
the same I'm gonna compile oppa here I
get something different here I get 40
and here I get eight so this is a big
difference what is happening well when I
call here the size of my constant
pointer what am I getting well I'm
getting the size of a pointer
that you know by now that uh this is
eight bytes right depending on the
machine in my machine is eight bytes on
the contrary when I call here size off
on the array what is happening well I am
getting the size of the entire array I'm
not getting the size of a pointer you
see the catch and get in size of array
which is 10 per 4 because this is the
size of all the objects so I have an
object in memory which is 40 bytes here
I have a pointer I don't have an object
of 40 bytes I have a pointer and in
every location in my stack I'm gonna put
manually all these values you see this
is a big difference already
now let's try uh with another operator
which is uh the Ampersand operator
so I'm gonna copy this I'm going to
print a pointer to the address of array
and then just beneath I'm gonna do the
pointer to array so I want to do the
same operation with my fake array so
using the Ampersand I'm going to do
printf percent p uh so address of PTR
and as well PTR by himself
why it is going to happen here my
friends let's watch carefully compile
and then just launch
you see something peculiar with the
array I get the same address both when I
use the Ampersand here and when I don't
use it these are the same pointer the
same address but they are of different
type here I have a pointer to array of
type in this case I have a pointer to an
array of um 10 integers and here I just
have a normal pointer to an integer so
they of course point to the same memory
location but they have a different type
what does it mean well it means that if
I perform pointer arithmetic with this I
get a different result respecting to
this one let's try so I'm gonna do that
pointer arithmetic
and this time as you can see I'm doing
puncture arithmetic to this pointer and
to this pointer which you just saw they
are the same let's try out I'm going to
compile and launch
look at that my friend what do you see
they of course point out the same
address but when I perform a plus one I
don't Advanced equally here I only
Advance uh for a position on the
contrary here advance much more indeed
here I jumped one array position this is
of course hexadecimal notation so pay
attention to that so when I use
um the Ampersand on the name of the
array Agata pointer which is of a
different type respecting to this name
of the array alone so I get a different
pointer arithmetic recall from the
previous videos I told you that the data
type of the pointer is going to imply
the way by which we read data in the
respective memory pointed and the
pointer arithmetic itself this is what
is happening on the contrary here what
you have I have a pointer to a pointer
and here I have a simple pointer so if I
do the same trick so I'm gonna do this
and that and yeah I'm gonna say plus one
and here plus one and it's going to
happen compile so I get those results so
this is the address of the pointer this
is the pointer itself this is the
address of the pointer plus one and this
is the pointer plus one of course this
is not a very well written I should have
written the output better but but you
get the point I guess this is the
address of the pointer when I say
pointer plus one I jump here I jump
eight because a pointer is eight bytes
here in the contrary I say pointer plus
one I jump four because an integer is
four bytes so let's not dig too much
into these technical stuff which is not
easy and let's understand the overall
idea so I have these two uh objects an
array and a fake quote-unquote array
that I created they are basically the
same they both allocate memory in the
stack this is happening because it's an
array you know how it works you have a
location in memory here on the contrary
I perform myself via location using
these function which is not suggest
tested but that's how it works so it's
gonna allocate 40 bytes in the stack
this is a constant pointer to an integer
almost like this so both are in the
stack okay
I cannot increase array as well as I
cannot increase PTR because this is a
constant the difference is that when I
use size off I'm going to get the size
of all the object of all the array when
I use size all for my pointer I get the
size of my pointer because this is just
a pointer
when I use the Ampersand I get the
address of the pointer on the contrary
when I use the Ampersand on an array I
get the address of the array that's type
so I get a pointer of a specific data
type in this case I get an address to an
array ins 10 so we get these uh things
which are not equal and now let's
understand why let's understand what is
going on we have these array pointer
Duality the best analogy that comes to
my mind is the
wave particle duality right of quantum
mechanics we don't actually know if a
particle is a wave or a particle because
sometimes it is ba is like a particle
sometimes CPA is like a wave and that's
all confusing so in the same way we have
arrays and pointers sometimes there are
arrays when I use the size of operator
and sometimes they are just pointers
when I just
um dereference the first element it is
just a pointer on the end of the day so
know this is confusing indeed my friend
there is this phenomenon which is called
array decay in which uh the array
basically is a pointer okay you can
perceive the array as a pointer and this
is the message I want to convey to you
we don't want to get bogged down into
technical details we just want to write
code
so my suggestion to you is that when you
work with an array identifier much
probably that is just a pointer to the
first element okay here are just uh
created this stupid model standard model
of arrays and pointers by which we have
an array that always decays into a
pointer to the first element but not in
all situations for example when we want
to increment the name of the array you
just saw we cannot do that we cannot
increase the name of an array when we
use the Ampersand operator with an array
we get the address of the array that's
type we don't get an address of a
pointer okay we get an address that has
a specific type that is the type of the
array in Array 10 in the case before so
it's kind of tricky right this array
decaying is kind of a tricky Beast to to
master now let's see what is written in
the C standard so except when I use the
size of operand or the Ampersand Opera
it or a string literal to initialize an
array an expression that has Type array
of type we have a conversion to an
expression of pointer to type so the
array is decaying into a pointer that
points to the initial elements of the
array okay so this is essentially what
is happening and keep in mind the
circuit model I've created because I
think I think it's fairly useful it
gives you the idea of what is going on
so let's write together a little piece
of code so we can understand better this
idea so as usual my main function at the
top and then I creates an array of 10
elements two integer like always so I
know that every time the array
identifier is going to Decay into a
pointer to the first element but not
always like fedu Prince have you saw
before Zoo
size of V we don't have the K here the
value is going to be 40 and not 8 right
but if I do something like that I do PTR
and then I do PTR is equal to V
what is happening here well I'm not
assigning an array to the pointer I'm
assigning a pointer to the first element
you see so here if I say V in position
zero is equal to 42. here I can see that
value just with the printf
and I say at PTR this is exactly the
same right so I'm gonna run as you can
see this is the size of the object and
this is the element in the first
position accessed through the pointer
see because here I have a Decay here I
don't have the K why because I'm using
the size of operator so the Decay as
well doesn't hold if I'm using the
Ampersand operator so before so I just
remove this here I'm getting the address
of the array which is equal to the
pointer to the first element but is of a
different type this is the key
difference and basically that's it I
don't want to give you too many details
because at a certain point you don't
need to stress out too much when you
work with a race you have an object
allocated in the stack and this is
different from a pointer an array is not
a pointer the trick is that very often
an array the case into a pointer so we
can basically consider an array like
pointer the thing is so intertwined that
basically I can use
pointer notation like that to access
elements inside my array I want the
object I position V plus one okay so I'm
gonna do
B1 is equal to 42 but I access with
pointer notation why well because this
is a pointer my friend this is a pointer
so so I'm gonna run that's the same you
see so what is at the end of the day the
difference between array accessing in
this fashion or in this fashion like
that well there is no difference indeed
they are the same the square bracket
notation at the end of today is just
syntactic sugar it is easier to perceive
what is going on with this way of typing
but underneath the hood what is
happening is that we get the reference
of a pointer you see coming back to a
previous principle that I explained in a
previous video we have C which is
consistent and regular in its approach
to address arithmetic right it's
integration of pointers arrays and
address arithmetic is one of the
strengths of the language that's why
pointer arithmetics works the way it
works it's basically array indexing
right when I increase by one and pointer
to a short I'm increasing by two
positions because I want to access the
following short the following object so
um when the compiler sees this uh V
square bracket one what is happening is
that it converts this to that okay plus
one
so we can do something really murky now
we can do that we can do printf on the
same but this time I'm gonna do one in
position V oh my god do you think it's
gonna work one in position with this
doesn't make any sense but let's try
well you see it works as well because
what is the thing here at the end of the
day the compiler is going to translate
this into this so it's the same right at
the end of the day this is commutative
this is the same thing so we can do
really strange stuff because at the end
we have the referencing of a pointer now
let me show you some other queries just
to have fun and not to learn this stuff
because it's very bad programming but
you can do printf for example the chart
in a string literal in a string literal
that it is an array of chart in C so I
do hello and I take the one position
three or let's do the one in position
zero let's take the H do you think it's
gonna work let's run so it's going to
give me back the H because this string
literal is an array underneath the wood
and this is array indexing but I told
you that this is just like
um pointer referencing so we can do this
okay that's right I'm gonna run as you
can see I get two h's and the same or I
can do something like that at 2 and it's
gonna be so bad to see this is gonna
give me back an l h l as you can see
right now you understood the trick right
we don't have to go any deeper you can
do super strange stuff given the nature
of reality in C so the message I want to
convey to you is that arrays are arrays
and pointers and pointers they are
indeed different things but as Drake is
telling us to drag the adjuster pointer
end of the story bit rake be cool
because when you're working with a race
unless you're using the size of operator
or the Ampersand operator or so forth
you are handling a pointer to the first
element so in your mind you can think
okay this is a pointer to the first
element end of the story so now let's
try to respond to some questions and the
first one is why it is already Decay
well it's fairly simple right uh if you
reach this level of the course you know
that when an object is the key into a
pointer we have a reference to it so
let's pretend we have a very very big
array and we are passing to a function
well we are not passing a copy so the
function doesn't have to copy all the
the thing but it just have a reference
to it so is efficient in memory usage
when passing an array to a function
instead of creating copying so when
passing a rateway function we are now
creating a big copy and this improves
performance overall right so you see
this little stupid program I have my
main inside my main I'm going to declare
a big array and then I pass to Foo Foo
is going to receive just a pointer even
though you're a write a square bracket
this is a point enter when I write a
square bracket I just say hey keep in
mind that in the main I have an array in
Auto pointer but they are the same right
you can do like that or like that so the
full function is going to receive only a
pointer to the array is not going to
receive a copy of that it's not going to
copy all the array in its local frame of
course here I can write in these two
Fashions it's totally the same so I
compile and launch you see cool so
adding this Decay uh is going to improve
your memory usage this is flexible of
course because every array has a
specific data type I can have in the
examples of before I have array int 10
array int 15 array double 30 you know so
for every array I would need an a doc
function I don't want to have many many
functions that are dealing with specific
array types I have an array that is the
key into a pointer so a pointer is a
pointer so I can have a generic function
that is able to perform its operation to
every kind of array the bad part is that
I have loss of size information
basically when I pass an array to a
function I don't know any or how big is
this array so I need the time to bring
with me an anchor value which is uh the
size right every time I call a function
I have this cumbersome size that I need
to pass or I can use a sentinel value
for example interleaved inside the
values in my array I can have a value
for example a negative value given that
my array is only positive values that is
will apply as essential value but you
know you have to engineer a way to
communicate to the cool function that
this is an array of on a specific type
what is the deal here let's try with the
code to explain why this is important
you see here I have my little code with
a symbolic constant with a value 100
size symbol in constant so I create my
array which has 100 elements then I go
to populate my array with random values
then I want to call my function
which is print elements and I gave us an
input my array V okay now print elements
would like to print the values inside my
array all the values but it doesn't know
how you see because I have my for Loop
which has the exit condition when I is
minor than what given that V here is
only a pointer you see the catch so here
I need to pass the size so we are gonna
pass a size and here I'm gonna put
int size okay so here I do is minor than
size now we can work you see to make it
Crystal Clear if I do printf zoo of D
here I'm I'm gonna get
um I like that size of V here I'm gonna
get eight and not the size 100 so let's
run this code and let's try to see what
is going on 14 on core size and here I
have all the random values which are
inside my array the first one of course
is the value 8 which is the size of the
pointer received
here there is a little mistake there
shouldn't be size of it so let's try to
launch again and then here I want to
tweak a little bit the code to make it
more readable let's do model 101 so I
have numbers ranging from 0 to 100 while
launch okay now I have all the numbers
that I want and here at the beginning I
have my 8 which is the size of the
pointer basically the name of the array
that at this level has decayed into a
pointer so I guess you understand what
is going on okay all the time so I need
to bring with me this size
value otherwise the code function
doesn't really know how big the array is
so like all the things we have pros and
cons trade-offs now the the question
that you just saw before so I'm not
gonna repeat why array index 5 is equal
to 5 index array you know because at the
end of the day we are de-referencing a
pointer so very shortly the C standard
defines the square bracket operator like
the referencing right so array and index
expression is equal to pointer and
offset that's totally the same so if I
say array 5 I'm saying at array plus
five and if I say five array I'm saying
at five plus arrays so you see I'm just
inverting the values and of course this
is commutative and that's no problem at
all but you understand this idea right
okay we're finished with this
um Duality array and pointers I try to
explain as the best as I can but I
understand that this is tricky this is
tricky keep in mind this idea an array
is an array but most probably is going
to Decay into a pointer to its first
element so you have this standard model
of array and pointers by which an array
is just a pointer in your mind and
believe me every time I write code I
think I basically forget that an array
is an array at the end of the day so for
any practical purpose they are the same
now pedantically speaking you understand
that they are not okay my friend now we
understood all the big principles
related to pointers now we go a little
leaper so we're gonna do now pointers to
pointers to pointers to pointers and so
forth right we are going to understand
how these work okay the thing is that
basically you can create arbitrary
complex objects right arbitrary complex
pointers let me tell you that in real
code you don't very often stumble upon
more than three levels pointers on the
contrary double pointers are totally
normal so let's just watch this stupid
program that contains a string and a
pointer to a string I have a string Char
star and then I have a pointer to that
string that I call PTR as you can see
this is a double pointer right because
the string is itself a pointer so PTR is
a pointer to a pointer so when you
declare a pointer to a pointer you have
this structure this is a visual
representation of what is going on as
you can see pointer is an 8 byte in my
system object that is pointing to
another hate byte object Str as well is
pointing to the first Char of the string
hello so if you watch carefully you can
see that inside these two pointers you
have the address right inside the SDR
you have the address of the letter H
inside my string and inside my PTR I
have the address of SDR right you can
clearly see thanks to the color and
thanks to the hexadecimal notation
indeed we use hexadecimals because
they're very cozy when we want to very
clearly see groups of nibbles so at the
end of the day that's what it is you can
have a pointer to a pointer to a Char
easy right of course let me repeat to
you you can create arbitrary complex
objects a very deep multi-level pointer
of course this is not recommended
because more than three level pointers I
would say the code starts to become
unreadable and this is super bad
especially for you that you have to read
again the code that you wrote you won't
be able to understand your own code now
let's watch an example which is crystal
clear because we use on a daily basis so
the these inputs are argument counter
and argument Vector you have seen many
many times right you can also have
environment variables but no it's not
the point so I have this argument Vector
which is a pointer to a pointer to a
chart so that's perfect we can analyze
this idea of pointers to pointers thanks
to this argument Vector so we are not
going to talk about something which is
poorly theoretical we are going to talk
about something which is pretty useful
on a daily basis so here my friend I
have a little algorithm that is able to
print all the charts inside argument
vector and this is a very good
representation of what argument bacteria
is as you can see you have a pointer
argument Vector that is pointing to a
series of pointers that here I have
depicted as an array of pointers later I
will explain better this idea in my
algorithm I have two iterators which are
J and K the classic names and then I
simply do a nested while loop with this
nested while loop I'm able to print all
the charts of course I want to print
Char by chart because I want to make
extremely clear how the structure work
so let's start the loop I want to make
with you very visually we have initially
J which is equal to zero so I have arc V
that is pointing to the first pointer
with the one in position zero after that
I have a k is equal to zero this is a
refresh operation I want K every time to
be zero so this is going to be the first
chart of my string then I simply do a
loop while arc V J K print that Char
okay so initially I'm going to print the
points of course here I don't use is
different from zero because this is
redundant I'm gonna use directly the
backslash zero as a Boolean value so
this is the inner while loop that is
working so I'm gonna do while Arc VJ in
position K I'm gonna loop I go in the
first position of the string then I'm
going in the second and in the third and
so forth right until I reach the final
back slash zero this final backslash
zero is going to act as a Boolean value
you know that in C 0 is equal to false
so this while loop is gonna break I have
a put s so this is gonna print a new
line I go in the following line and then
I just increase J so I go in the
following pointer boom you see K is
going to be refreshed and then I do
again the same thing you see I Loop
inside all the charts until I stumble
upon the backslash zero here the
condition is going to become false so
again the while loop is gonna break I
print a new line and then boom I go in J
equal to you see and then I do the same
thing I'm going to print all the string
until at the end I'm going to assemble
upon this null this null my friend is a
sentinel value so thanks to this null I
can say okay I don't have any more
strings in my argument Vector so here my
friend we have the actual program that
you just saw so here for example I have
my program that I'm going to launch for
example I don't know I'm gonna have a
DOT out and some inputs for example
hello there okay these are gonna be the
strings that are gonna be written so
let's try to compile and launch I'm
gonna launch with an input for example
hello there how are you boom and as you
can see I have in my standard output all
these strings you see cool so this is a
little algorithm that is gonna Loop
inside the strings pointed by RV here of
course I use the square bracket notation
because it is more intuitive do you
agree but you know that this is just at
the end of the day syntactic sugar I can
do also like that let's try I can do at
Earth V plus J right and here I can do
these are more complicated but it's
gonna be at RTV plus J and then I'm
gonna do at R3 plus J is going to be the
reference plus K like that
cool uh let's try to launch again the
code and let's watch if it's gonna work
again as you can see it works exactly
the same because I did exactly the same
thing I'm sure you agree that the square
bracket notation is far far better far
far more intelligible than this one
right so it's far better to use this
and the square bracket notation if you
watch carefully really recalls the cell
right inside our Vector our array we
have the first cell the first level and
then the second level which is the chart
itself you see it's fairly intelligible
to see what is going on if you have a
clear diagram in your mind so with the
first J I'm selecting the string with
the K I'm selecting the chart itself now
here I have the pro version of the
program basically I say while at
argument vector and while at AV right
you remember from the previous video
when I told you that when I double the
reference this I get the chart because I
can see in its signature right I have if
I double the reference this object here
I get the chart if I singlely reference
this object what do I get well I get a
pointer to a charm so here is written
while I have a pointer to a chart and
here I just omitted this it's different
from null right and wild B
is different from zero you print all the
stuff here I use the the pointer
notation to your reference you see how
cryptic it is it's far better to use the
square bracket notation when we have
multi-level pointers anyway let's try to
launch this and see if it works and as
you can see it works exactly like the
previous one cool now my friend I'm sure
you many times have seen this signature
in the main right so you can have star
arc V array or you can have a double
star arcv what is the difference here
now given that you understand these
array pointer Duality from the previous
video I'm sure you now understand what
is going on well my friend the problem
is always the same array decay
so here my friend I have a little
program that is creating a fake main you
see that he's taking an argument vector
and here I'm creating in my main
function an argument Vector so this is
what thanks to the right left rule right
we start from the identifier then if we
can we go right and then we go left
array of pointers to chart so this is
the initialization of the array I'm
going to insert directly the strings
right given that this is an array of
strings at the end I'm gonna put an all
then what do I do I call the fake main
function and I pass AV but you remember
right that arrays have this peculiarity
that are going to Decay to a pointer to
the first element so we don't really
care if the objects inside the array are
Pointers themselves they could have been
integers floats doesn't really matter
the thing is that we have an array so
you know that when we pass an array the
function fake main is going to receive a
pointer a pointer what a pointer to a
pointer because this array contains
pointers that is what is going on let's
try this code and let's convince
ourselves that this is true so I'm going
to run the code and as you can see I
have the inputs that I've given inside
my array now we have to understand a
point here I want to do this operation
creating av1 which is a pointer to a
pointer and then I do the same thing as
here I initialize this pointer to
pointer like here but I cannot do that
let's try to compile this code and let's
see the mistake
so I'm going to compile as you can see I
cannot do this operation incompatible
pointer types initializing chart star
star with an expression of type Char 5.
the thing is that at this level this is
an array of pointers an array so we have
an allocation of space in this case we
have an allocation of one two three four
five pointers so 40 bytes and as I told
you this is an array array and pointers
are not the same thing they behave
similarly in certain conditions but they
are not the same here I just have a
pointer so what what am I doing here I'm
assigning this thing to this object it's
not this is not possible this is not
visible this makes no sense I can do
that here I can do this is equal to AV
this is legal and why it is legal well
because you know that the identifier of
an array is gonna Decay to a pointer to
the first element so here I have a
pointer to a pointer okay that's all
there is I think you understand super
well what is going on so here of course
I can write like this or like that it's
exactly the same here when we write in
the cold function an array it is just to
stress out that in the Kohli function we
have an array we are manipulating an
array and what we are using the cold
function is just a pointer so let's run
again as you can see it works perfectly
okay I think you understand what is
going on right so my humble suggestion
is always the same just keep in mind
that an array probably in your code is
just a pointer if something bad happens
just remember that array are arrays so
probably it is an exception the array as
a decade so if you want to train a
little bit with these pointers to
pointers you can come here instituter
and do some code for example you can do
PTR
and equal 42 double PTR triple PTR okay
so you do many level pointers same let's
do till four PTR okay
so we do yeah always the same name
PTR one two and three and then I say PTR
is equal to the address of n ptr1 is
equal to the address of PTR you see
ptr2 is equal to the address of pcr1
with your 3 is equal to the address of
ptr2
okay let's try to launch this code
and here you see you have a beautiful
representation you have the number and
you have PTR here that is pointing to 42
then what do you have you have ptr1 that
is pointing to here I made a mistake
with your three I want like that okay
let's launch again so I have 42 I have a
pointer 242 then I have pointer one that
is pointing to PDR then I have pointer 2
that is pointing to be there one and
then I have pointer three that is
pointing to PR2 you see that's the
structure that you can expect here we
can also see the memory addresses so we
can have a better understanding of what
is going on and you can create all the
mess that you want with these pointers
okay just I highly suggest you to come
to his website and work out a little bit
uh these ideas okay that's all there is
with this uh double pointers I don't
want to dig two down because this can
become very complex so my friend here we
are in the last chapter of this mini
course uh we're gonna talk about Pointer
to functions I'm not gonna go very deep
first of all because these starts to be
a little complicated and generally
speaking pointer to functions are not
super used of course this boils down to
the type of code you're writing but I
would say initially if you are a
beginner and if you are watching this
kind of videos you are not gonna really
use pointers functions anyway this is
just a gentle introduction I would like
you to understand what is going on with
pointer to functions and take home the
overall ideas the overall principles so
you know that a function is a symbol
that you can call to get some action
right to perform some performance
specific task for example the printf
when you call the printf you would like
to see on the terminal something written
and indeed that's what it is but
functions can be also pointers so let's
read together this line the only things
you can do with a function is to call it
or to take its address so if the name is
not followed by the brace the round
brace well it means that I don't want
the function to be called but I want
something different in it I want the
address of the function so take a
message if you write the name of the
function without the round brace it
means that you want the address it is
kind of similar if you want to the array
Decay right when you use the name of the
array it's going to indicate to the
pointer to the first element well in
this case it's similar if you want the
principle is similar if you use the name
of the function it's gonna quote unquote
the K into the address to the function
so let's understand better this idea
here as you can see I have my process
memory layout so when you launch your
program you know that the operating
system is giving you a space in memory
which has this shape now where in my
process memory layout the function Foo
in this case a stupid function that is
returning me the value 42 lives in the
stack in the hip where is this function
well it turns out that the function
lives in the text area indeed the text
also called the code segment contains
the instructions of your program
instructions are bare bone binaries that
are telling to the computer to do
something you don't have to go too deep
into this stuff or better if you want
that would be marvelous but it's low low
level stuff so the binary of the
function full the instruction leave in
this section in my process memory layout
so if you watch carefully a princess is
trying to print a pointer you see from
the identity identifier P Foo is a
function but I'm not using with the
round brace so you know from before that
this is the address of the function form
so this is the program my friend and now
we're gonna launch so I'm gonna compile
and now I'm gonna launch okay here it
comes I have this address which is kinda
peculiar right it's very different from
the kind of address that we get from a
variable let me explain better if here I
do ends and B and B equal 13.
and I print the two addresses okay so p
and p areas full and here I use the
address of ND so I'm going to compile
and launch you see they are very
different very very different one is
this quote-unquote little number on the
contrary our variable lives here
now I want to explain you something to
do that I use the slip function so
include uni STD and here I do a sleeper
100 okay so I want my process to not die
to stay alive because I want to check
this process memory layout so I'm gonna
compile and then just launch with the
number sent so I have the terminal I can
use the terminal even though the process
is running on the background so enter
now I check PS here immediately you can
see the the addresses right the printf
has worked so I say PS you can see that
the process is running now I do virtual
memory map of the process and then I
pipe this into less this is just a way
to see better what is inside the output
of the command virtual memory map okay
Enter
now with this command I can see the
virtual memory layout which is this one
now we have this address which is this
one 105 30 6f 20. let's see if we can
find here 105 30 36 F so here we go from
30 to 105 30 70. so you see that
um the add result function is here is in
this range and if you watch carefully
this is the text range here it is a
non-writable region of course we cannot
change the values inside the text here
on the contrary we have this value 7ff I
already know that this is the stack of
course so let's search for the stack as
you can see here maybe is in this range
here 7f e e a zero seven f e e a eight
so here I have a eight fd00
fc92 C you see so I have the variable
which lives in this range so I have one
range here on the contrary I have the um
function that is leaving in this range
okay so this is low level stuff
technical stuff but just to give you a
glimpse so this is uh the abstract view
that I propose to you in which we have
our function that lives inside this
place now let's zoom in a little bit so
we have our function food that lives
inside the text segment and basically
this Foo is a pointer to instruction
zero if you want of the function full so
instruction zero of the function Foo as
that specific address inside the text
segment you see to make it clear if we
have more functions for example add
subtract multiply divide we are going to
have multiple pointers that are gonna
point to the instruction 0 of the
relative function you see that's where
it is my friend that's what is going on
now my friend I have a little program to
understand this concept of pointer
functions okay given the principle given
the knowledge that you now have we're
gonna understand the in this program so
here immediately you can see that I have
uh four prototypes right for function
add subtract multiply and divide you
immediately notice that they all have
the same signature they all have the
same prototype because they give me back
an integer and a take as an input an
integer okay here I have another
function it is called performed
arithmetic and this is a special
function because it's going to exploit
function pointers so the function is
taking two integers and this strange
thing here you see this my friend is a
pointer to a function it has this way of
writing essentially it is almost like a
prototype the only difference is that we
have these run braces here and indeed
when it comes to uh pointer2 functions
the syntax is not very simple so now
look there in my main I have a
declaration of two variables A and B and
here I want to perform arithmetic in
this case I want to perform the addition
so I call the function perform
arithmetic and I give as an input add
that is the name of a function right is
the name of this function here I've
defined add ear this is a very silly
function that is returning a plus b
but here I'm able to pass add that now
you know is just the address of the
instructions in the text so it's just an
address to the function so here every
time I call perform arithmetic but with
a different pointer right every time I
change the pointer to the function
perform arithmetic only knows that it's
gonna receive a function with a specific
signature and that's the important part
the thing is that a pointer has to be
consistent if you want to use in this
fashion all the pointers have to be an
integer as a return and two integers as
an input so let's try to launch this
code and let's watch if it works so I'm
going to compile so here I have the sum
which is 10 plus 5 is equal 15 of course
and the address of the sum function is
this one I have the difference I I get
five this is the address of the
difference as you can see it's fairly
close right it's fairly close one each
other we have only a gap of 20 in
hexadecimal of course so it's going to
be a gap of 32 bytes here I have the
multiplication and here I have the
quotient so the division
okay it works so at the end of the day
the name of a function is just
an address a spot in your memory in
which you have the relative instructions
to achieve the goal of the function
itself right here with pointer functions
we are exploiting this property I repeat
to you that it is important that the
signature is the same now let's try to
change a little bit I'm going to do
another integer
and this time immediately I get a
warning and installing and it's telling
me incompatible
um function pointer because you can see
that this is another type right I have
another type of pointer so it's giving
me a warning because I have a pointer to
function that has another signature
respected to the one that the function
is able to take the last thing we have
to demystify is a little bit the syntax
which is kinda super tricky of pointers
to function so we go in the this website
which is gibberish to see and we're
gonna type
for example int
and then we are going to do I don't know
pointer tofu and then we're gonna do ins
and as you can see I have declared full
as a pointer to function that takes two
integers and return an integer
now why it is important to use the round
braces here well let's try to remove
them this is a prototype as you can see
we're declaring Foo as a function the
user returning a pointer to an integer
so that's the problem on the contrary if
I say hey you have to read this together
I'm saying ah I see so this fool is a
pointer to a function you get it now of
course here I have all the the values
that I can have and that's all there is
this is the way by which you can declare
a pointer to a function I want to stress
out that I don't use pointers to
function uh very often but it's useful
to know how they work so I just gave you
the overall principle the overall idea a
function name is just a fancy way of
talking about an address in memory
article to you that all the names all
the variable names function names are
just an abstraction for us to
um read the code but at the end of the
day we have only numbers we have only
addresses we have only binary values all
the symbols are just an abstraction for
us okay my friend I think that with this
mini course you have a better
understanding of pointers hopefully I
really hope basically this is the video
I wanted to watch when I started to
learn about the C programming language
of course there is a lot more to dig to
understand to practice because pointers
are a tremendous bad Beast to tame but
these I think is a very good
introduction all right my friend thank
you for watching take care